dos santos et flûte claude
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne
l'audition de patrick devedjian par la
commission des finances du sénat le
ministre en charge de la relance a été
entendu hier par les sénateurs
il a rappelé que 13 milliards d'euros
ont déjà été injectés dans l'économie
française sur les 26 milliards prévus
par le plan de relance ce qui a permis
selon lui de créer et de préserver près
de 250 mille emplois une réactualisation
du plan de relance n'est donc pas à
l'ordre du jour selon lui
je vous propose d'écouter l'intégralité
de son audition bonne matinée à tous sur
public sénat monsieur le ministre l a
commission des finances du sénat est
heureuse de vous accueillir aujourd'hui
pour cette audition qui a lieu salle
clemenceau elle a lieu salle clémenceau
puisque nous avons souhaité y associer
nos collègues des commissions des
affaires sociales de la culture et de
l'économie dont je salue la présence à
nos côtés et spécialement le président
et maureen au nom de l'ensemble des
sénateurs présents je vous confirme que
nous sommes sensibles au fait que vous
teniez votre engagement d'un puis-je
dire reporting trimestriel devant le
parlement
notre rendez vous précède en outre de
quelques jours la tenue au sénat du
débat d'orientation sur les finances
publiques pour 2010 c'est donc à ces
deux titres que nous vous entendons et
que nous allons vous interrogez nous
sommes ici pour évoquer le plan annoncé
le 4 décembre 2008 par le président de
la république est élaboré par étapes
successives mais rapprocher dans les
semaines qui ont suivi en particulier
les trois lois de finances rectificative
adopté en décembre 2008 et avril 2009 et
la loi du 17 février 2009 pour
l'accélération des programmes de
construction et d'investissement publics
et privés
sa mise en oeuvre incombe à une
pluralité d'acteurs le gouvernement bien
sûr que l'on imagine totalement
mobilisés et qui a tenu au mois de
février un comité interministériel
d'aménagement et de compétitivité des
territoires au cours duquel des projets
ont été sélectionnés parmi ses acteurs
il y a les opérateurs de l'état mais
aussi les collectivités territoriales
sur lesquels reposent les trois quarts
de l'investissement public et quelques
entreprises publiques qui ont accepté
d'accélérer la réalisation de certains
de leurs investissements
vous êtes présence sur le terrain
puisque depuis la mi-avril votre agenda
mentionne en moyenne un déplacement par
semaine et peut-être même plus assez les
chemins est relativement stable mais
pour veiller à l'adéquation entre les
moyens mis en oeuvre et les besoins des
territoires
vous vous êtes entouré de sept
parlementaires dont deux sénateurs
françois noël buffet et françois
zocchetto qui sont ici cet après midi
qui chacun dans sa région sont les
ambassadeurs de la relance j'imagine que
la mise en oeuvre de votre feuille de
route vous occupe déjà
largement toutefois il ne vous aura pas
échappé que l'éventualité d'un second
plan de relance financés par le grand
emprunt fait l'objet de commentaires
quotidiens dont vous nous direz
peut-être un mot pour ma part j'aimerais
vous entendre sur trois sujets
lorsque vous étiez venu devant nous le 6
janvier vous aviez fait part de votre
détermination à aplanir les obstacles y
fut parfois des règles héritées de la
culture administrative française sur ce
point
avez vous avancé deuxième
deuxième sujet que je voudrais évoquer
le cas juste je souhaiterais vous
entendre d'une manière générale sept
mois après la création de votre
ministère et compte tenu de l'évolution
de la conjoncture économique mondiale
considérez vous que ce plan contribue
déjà à soutenir l'activité et qui est de
nature pour reprendre la définition que
le dictionnaire donne de la relance a
donné une nouvelle impulsion à
l'économie française
et puis enfin troisième sujet nous
reconnaissons tous le rôle que prennent
les collectivités territoriales et dans
l'investissement public n'est pas
douteux que l on était totalement
mobilisé en 2009 et que la mesure assez
exceptionnel qui a consisté à mettre à
la disposition des budgets locaux
le fonds de compensation tva 2000
7 et celui de 2008
il n'est pas douteux que vous avez
trouvé là un accélérateur
d'investissements publics
je doute que 2009 suffisent pour
conforter la relance est donc en 2010 ne
faudra-t-il pas reprendre cet excellent
dispositif et mettre à la disposition
des collectivités territoriales qui
s'engagerait dans des niveaux
d'investissement participant à la
relance consolidant la relance
les fonds de compensation de tva
correspondant aux investissements 2009
et 2010 je ministre vous avez la parole
si monsieur le président sur pour koné
le mérite de la persévérance en tout
état de cause
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances sur le président de la
commission de l'économie monsieur le
rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
alors vous le vous l'avez 10 le plan de
relance initié par le président de la
république le 4 décembre constitue
évidemment un effort mais il prolonge
ils prolongent une série de dispositions
qui contribuent également à surmonter la
crise fondé sur l'investissement
il a été enrichi
mesures de solidarité en direction des
ménages et des salariés qui étaient
touchés dans leur emploi
il est temporaire et ciblée il sa
réussite est largement subordonné à
notre capacité collective à le conduire
rapidement alors c'est un effort massif
le plan de relance porte sur un effort
nouveau de l'ordre de 2 30 milliards
d'euros s'inscrit en effet dans le
prolongement des mesures prises dès le
mois d'octobre
en réponse à la crise financière
internationale dont la faillite de
lehman brothers aux etats-unis a été
l'un des révélateurs les plus
spectaculaires pour l'opinion publique
et pour les marchés cette crise a
conduit à prendre des mesures de soutien
au système financier pour conforter
notamment le financement de l'économie
ces mesures je le rappelle se sont
traduites en particulier par la
mobilisation de 320 milliards d'euros
pour renforcer et garantir les banques
d'une garantie et la mise en place de 22
milliards d'euros pour faciliter le
financement des pme
social c'est donc un effort en lui même
massif qui s'inscrit dans un contexte et
un mouvement qui met en jeu des
grandeurs considérable cette dimension
ne doit pas être absente de notre
raisonnement et de notre analyse
lorsqu'on se livrent notamment à des
comparaisons internationales
le plan de relance que nous développons
en france depuis quelques mois
maintenant s'appuie sur un volet
important en faveur de l'investissement
en effet l'un l'effort d'investissement
public est supérieure à 10 par
prise public deux milliards et demi est
en réalité trois et demie probablement
au titre du remboursement du fctva aux
collectivités locales qui s'engage à
investir
l'effort direct exceptionnel
d'investissement de l'état porte sur les
infrastructures plus d'un milliard
d'euros l'enseignement supérieur 730
millions d'euros le patrimoine de l'état
620 millions d'euros la culture la
justice la défense le patrimoine des
administrations tout ceci avec une forte
orientation au profit de l'amélioration
de la performance énergétique
l'équipement de la défense occupe aussi
une place importante
un milliard et demi il s'agit
d'améliorer la compétitivité de nos
territoires et des acteurs économiques
qui travaillent leur au public investi
engendrera donc un retour sur
investissement et c'est ce que nous
recherchons les entreprises publiques se
sont associés à cet effort
edf avec deux milliards et demi la ratp
avec 450 millions la poste 600 millions
la sncf 384 gdf suez qui n'est pas
probant pas parlé une entreprise
publique mais dans lequel il ya une
présence publique 200 millions d'euros
les collectivités ont également été
incités à investir
comment n'en serait-il pas ainsi
lorsqu'on sait qu'elle réalise
vous l'avez rappelé les près des trois
quarts des investissements civil public
cette mesure est un succès et j'y
reviendrai on attend évidemment de
l'investissement un effet multiplicateur
l'intervention de l'état ne donne à cet
égard pas l'exacte mesure des volumes en
réalité par exemple les procédures
contractuelles suppose des
cofinancements tout comme la
construction de logements où
d'importants programmes de
réhabilitation des quartiers retenus
dans le cadre de la rénovation urbaine
cet effet multiplicateur se traduit bien
sûr par des commandes donc par des
salaires et ce cycle économique
arthur soutient la consommation qui se
tient d'ailleurs beaucoup mieux dans
notre pays qu'ailleurs ce programme
d'investissements a été complété par un
volet de soutien à l'activité économique
et à l'emploi
il comporte d'abord un ensemble de
mesures fiscales destinées à améliorer
la trésorerie des entreprises
et là encore l'effort et massif il se
traduira par une moindre recettes pour
le budget de l'état
cela est évalué à 9 milliards 9 d'euros
presque 10 au travers notamment de
mesures comme le remboursement du crédit
impôt recherche le le crédit impôt
recherche 3,8 milliards d'euros et donc
le carry back 1,8 milliard d'euros ou
l'accélération du remboursement de la
tva estimée à 3 milliards 6,7 un soutien
direct à la trésorerie des entreprises
un soutien très concret et qui à part
faire parfois permis aux entreprises les
vues avec de multiples exemples concrets
qui leur a permis de surmonter des
moments difficiles et certaines ont dû
de survivre à cela d'autres mesures
participent à ce soutien à l'économie en
même temps qu'elle contribue à une
démarche de justice sociale en direction
des salariés frappés dans leur emploi
ces mesures représentent 6,55 milliards
d'euros elles sont nombreuses et je ne
les évoquerait donc succinctement en les
regroupant un premier groupe auquel deux
milliards d'euros sont consacrés
s'attache à soutenir très directement
les entreprises c'est le cas de l'aide à
l'embauché dans les tpe
c'est le cas le dispositif de garantie
d'oseo
c'est également le cas du fonds de
sécurisation du crédit interentreprises
l'assurance crédit c'est-à-dire cap plus
c'est le cas d'autres mesures qui sont
sectoriels comme la prime à la casse
c'est aussi le plan de soutien à
l'automobile 2 milliards d'euros + 6
milliards
d'euros hors plan de relance hors plan
de relance mais en plus au sens strict
car il s'agit de prêts enfin d'autres
sont plus stratégiques au travers du fsi
par exemple dotées par l'état de 3
milliards d'euros et auxquels 490
millions d'euros ont déjà été versés à
ce jour
enfin deux mesures pour un milliard et
demi d'euros améliorons et améliorent
déjà la trésorerie des entreprises 500
millions d'euros pour régler les dettes
de la défense
un milliard d'euros pour les avances sur
marchés publics dont 450 millions
d'euros ont déjà été mobilisés le second
groupe de mesurer directement orientée
vers les salariés touchés dans leur
emploi et les jeunes
il correspond à l'ensemble des mesures
issues du sommet social du 18 février
dernier et du plan en faveur de l'emploi
des jeunes annoncées le 24 avril par le
président de la république et c'est
l'objet du fonds d'investissement social
fiso d'opter cette année d'un milliard 3
par l'état est également abondé par les
partenaires sociaux
ce programme ne comporte pas moins de
vingt mesures que je vais pas non plus
énumérer mais qui pour l'essentiel
s'attache à revaloriser le chômage
partiel comme moyen d'échapper à la
rupture du contrat de travail à
renforcer les dispositifs du type crp
ctp en faveur des licenciés économiques
à faciliter l'insertion des jeunes
notamment par le développement de la
formation en alternance à faciliter
l'embauché en cdi
ces politiques actives de l'emploi et de
formation devrait connaître un large
développement à la rentrée notamment
comme l'a indiqué le président de la
république
ces mesures s'étale sur 2009 et 2010
le dernier axe du plan de relance répond
à un objectif de solidarité
il est doté de 2 milliards 6 et comporte
un ensemble d'actions destinées à
promouvoir la construction à accroître
l'offre de logement social puisque c'est
plus de cent mille logements à soutenir
la rénovation urbaine et le traitement
de l'habitat indigne à développer les
structures d'accueil pour les plus
défavorisés à aider les plus pauvres et
à soutenir les ménages à revenus
modestes au travers de prestations
exceptionnelles 1 milliards 6,2 euros
environ ils sont consacrés 230 millions
d'euros 2 est resté à pour l'outre-mer
450 millions d'euros de primes et des
primes qui est à 150 euros pour les
familles modestes et 300 millions
d'euros de chaque emploi service cesu
pour 700 millions d'euros de prime de
solidarité active à cet exemple s'ajoute
un milliard cent d'euros de réductions
fiscales pour 6 millions de ménages
environ
ceux ci représentent donc une somme
importante
on le voit le plan est fondé sur
l'investissement pour préparer l'avenir
mais il ne néglige en rien la
consommation par un soutien très appuyé
aux plus défavorisés
l'emprunt national décidée par le
président de la république est annoncée
lors du congrès de versailles auquel
vous avez fait allusion prolongera cet
effort au profit de priorités ciblées
qui préparent l'avenir il sera assorti
de mesures propres à réduire les
dépenses de fonctionnement et à contenir
la dépense publique en l'orientant vers
la préparation de l'avenir il sera
préparé au travers d'une large
concertation pour en définir les
priorités
c'est donc un ensemble assez complet qui
a été définie pour provoquer un stimulus
rapide et on peut dire que la rapidité
de mise en oeuvre est en effet un
élément déterminant de l'efficacité du
plan de relance
chacun comprendra pourquoi la capacité
et dépend de la rapidité d'exécution
un seul chiffre illustre cette volonté
toutes les autorisations d'engagement
doivent être engagées cette année et les
trois quarts des paiements doivent
intervenir durant cette année 2009 cette
exigence qui est assez caractéristique
du plan français par rapport au plan
étrangers en fait souvent la différence
c'est le sens de la mission qui m'a été
confiée mission limitée dans le temps
que je conduis avec une équipe compacte
sans service administratif n'avait qu'
autorité sur une quinzaine de grandes
directions d'administration centrale la
gestion des moyens consacrés aux plans
de relance emprunte deux voix deux
techniques le transfert de crédits au
profit des ministères qui ont la
responsabilité de la conduite de
programmes et la gestion directe
c'est-à-dire le versement de moyens
directement à des agences ou organismes
qui ont la compétence dévolue par la loi
l'anru l'anah la fif de rff vnf ou qui
ont été désignées comme telles de la msp
pour la prime à la casse
la cnaf pour la psa la cnav pour le est
resté à etc
un tiers des crédits budgétaires environ
est géré par transfert et deux tiers par
voie directe
j'ai passé des conventions environ 45
avec chaque gestionnaire sur
l'utilisation les échéanciers leur
reporting
le pilotage de ces crédits par ailleurs
fléché dans les systèmes comptables
toujours dans le double souci faire plus
et faire vite faire vite c'était d'abord
choisir des opérations notamment
d'investissements prête à démarrer pour
que le plan est un impact dès maintenant
il n'était pas envisageable d'attendre
la fin de procédure pour retenir tel ou
tel projet est à cet égard ce qu'ils ont
observé
et n'avait pas de projet nous faut je
leur réponds que c'était un choix
délibéré pour pouvoir agir vite mais que
ces projets n'étaient pas financés que
par conséquent son plan de relance se
sera resté des projets dans les tiroirs
cet exercice a été fait concomitamment
au vote de la loi de finances
rectificative qui a mis en place le plan
le 4 février et avec un ciac que vous
avez retenu qui s'est tenu à lyon le 2
février et qui a sélectionné un peu plus
de 1000 opérations chiffre symbolique
1000 qui sera en réalité dépasse et
autour de 1200 c'est sur cette base que
nous avons mis les crédits à disposition
des ministères ou aux opérateurs chargés
de conduire ces mesures en précisant que
nous pourrions procéder à des retraits
des dégagement d'office en cas de non
respect des échéanciers encore
fallait-il pour être efficient se donner
les moyens de suivre et de piloter nous
avons fait le choix de nous appuyer sur
les préfets de région et pour de
multiples raisons pleuvait par exemple
l'existence des cars le suivi des
politiques contractuelles
la proximité des responsables de bopp
les capacités d'arbitrage de la rgpp et
nous avons mis au point un dispositif
qui nous permet de suive programme par
programme action par action et projet
par projet france entière et région par
région et même parfois département par
département l'état d'exécution du plan
avec un reporting automatisé
hebdomadaire ceci n'a pu être fait que
par adaptation de combinaisons et
croisement de systèmes d'information
nous avons enfin créer un site internet
pour permettre l'accès de chacun à
l'information et de suivi de chaque
chantier et ce site a un très grand
succès populaire
voilà pour le compte
la civi la signification et la mise en
place du plan maintenant où en
sommes-nous aujourd'hui effectivement
aujourd'hui nous sommes six mois après
l'annonce et plus de cinq mois après la
mise en oeuvre du plan de relance
d'abord les textes de simplification qui
ont été pris sont presque tous rendu
applicable décret loi de simplification
ordonnance sur les installations
classées par ailleurs 8 milliards et
demi d'euros d'autorisations
d'engagement ont été mis à disposition
des opérateurs et des ministères ainsi
qu'un peu plus de 6 milliards d'euros de
crédits de paiement 5 milliard sept
d'euros de crédits budgétaires et 500
millions d'euros de crédits de paiement
reporter sur cette somme 3 milliards 8
d'euros ont été payés
à cela s'ajoute un milliard d'euros de
commandes des entreprises publiques qui
ont elles mêmes payer 590 millions
d'euros alors fournisseurs à ce titre
les mesures fiscales ont conduit à
rembourser 6 milliards 8 d'euros à titre
définitif aux entreprises
au total ce sont 11,2 milliards d'euros
qui ont été injectés dans l'économie
depuis le début de mise en oeuvre du
plan de relance auquel il convient
d'ajouter les premiers versement du
fctva qui s'élève déjà à un milliard
huit à ce jour ce sont donc 13 milliards
d'euros qui ont bien été payé toute
action confondues naturellement 500
chantiers ont démarré ce sont des
opérations nouvelles ou des opérations
d'anticipation d'accélération
accélération pour laisser per
anticipations pour les opérations de
pdmi anticipation par exemple sur le bpc
le bateau de projection et de
commandement de la marine nationale
il peut s'agir de très grosses
opérations c'est le cas du bepc comme de
chantier plus modestes sur le patrimoine
par exemple il reste
que ces deux catégories de chantier
participent aux mêmes objectifs
accroître l'activité partout sur tout le
territoire et pour toutes les catégories
d'entreprises
c'est le sens même de la mesure du fctva
dont je vous disais tout à l'heure
qu'elle a été un grand est réel succès
en effet 19 1540 collectivités y ont
adhéré en prévoyant des investissements
supérieurs à 50 4 milliards d'euros
s'agissant des autres programmes trois
cent cinquante mille embauches dans les
tpe ont fait l'objet d'une demande
d'être zéro charges tpe avec sans doute
un effet d'aubaine mais aussi des
embauches qui ne se serait pas fait 230
mille véhicules ont bénéficié de la
prime à la casse n'est évidemment pas
sans lien avec la bonne tenue relative
du marché automobile en france
70000 logements sociaux ou en accession
sociale ont été financés depuis le début
en comptant le programme vefa l'anru et
le ptz des aides pour la rénovation de
17 mille logements de ménages modestes
ont été attribués par l'anah la prime de
solidarité active a été versée à 4,3
millions de ménages représente 860
millions d'euros afin d'anticiper
l'entrée en vigueur du rsa
la prime pour les familles modestes de
150 euros vient de l'être 450 millions
d'euros à 3 millions de ménages ont été
versés l'échec d'emploi les chèques
emploi service de 200 euros ont été
distribués tout au long du mois de juin
à un million cinq cent mille foyers le
est resté à d'un montant de 100 euros
par mois
le sera à partir de juillet en outre-mer
et cela représente 2 133 millions
d'euros jusqu'à fin 2009 oséo est
intervenu au profit de plus de 8500
entreprises pour garantir plus de 1,46
milliard d'euros de prêts le médiateur
du crédit a reçu plus de dix mille
dossiers et
été plus de 6800 avec un taux de succès
de 65%
le fsi et le fonds de modernisation des
équipementiers automobiles sont
intervenus à neuf reprises à hauteur de
535 millions d'euros
les choses ont démarré à ce jour au vu
des prévisions à trois mois
nous n'avons pas à faire un vaste
exercice de redéploiement de crédits
même si des substitutions d'opérations
sont nécessaires et se pratique déjà au
fil de la gestion il y a eu une grande
mobilisation des acteurs et en
particulier de l'administration
française qui fait écho à la
mobilisation internationale et sur ce
point le plan français dans le contexte
international que je voudrais conclure
la mobilisation internationale a été à
la hauteur de la brutalité du choc
la commission évalue à 400 milliards
d'euros les mesures prises à l'échelle
européenne
et on sait que le plan américain s'élève
à 787 milliards de dollars
celui du japon à 210 dans la plupart des
pays
l'effort repose sur l'investissement
sauf en grande-bretagne qui a privilégié
la consommation les etats unis ont
également un volet fiscal et social très
important qui peut se comprendre si l'on
comparé par exemple nos systèmes sociaux
le taux d'endettement des ménages et
l'impact de la crise immobilière
on peut chiffrer l'impact théorique des
plans étrangers sur l'économie française
à +0 7% en 2009 sur l'économie française
de ce point de vue les calendriers
diffère un peu même si le sentiment
d'urgence est partagé unanimement les
stimuli 2009 2010 sont plus concentrés
en 2009 en france au royaume uni au
japon et en espagne qu'ils ne le sont en
allemagne où la concentration semble
plus forte en 2010 reste
la mobilisation a été forte et a fait
émerger ou à renforcer la prise en
compte des préoccupations comme la
situation des pays émergents où la
nécessaire régulation régulation le
triplement des ressources du fmi qui
passe de 250 à 750 milliards d'euros en
est une illustration
la montée en puissance de pays comme le
brésil ou la chine dans le g20 en est
une autre
dans un autre registre en parallèle la
zone euro a démontré sa capacité de
réaction dans notre pays
le plan de relance aura aussi été un
élément fédérateur des volontés chacun
perçoit bien la difficulté de la
situation et la nécessité d'un effort
collectif et de solidarité pour
surmonter cette crise
c'est en particulier le sens des mesures
du fonds d'investissement social
le fiso s'est aussi d'une certaine
manière le sens de l'emprunt national
qui en même temps permettra de soumettre
l'investissement de leurs au public à
des critères de rentabilité d'utilité
d'efficacité qui contribuera à contenir
les dépenses courantes
c'est aussi me semble-t-il la
signification de l'engagement des
collectivités locales à l'évidence nous
devons poursuivre cet effort de manière
concertée pour être le plus efficace
possible
voilà monsieur le président ce que je
voulais vous dire avant de répondre plus
en détail peut-être aux questions que
vous me poserez et qui liminairement
portait sur trois questions est ce que
nous avons aplani les obstacles hérité
de la culture administratif
je crois que nous avons fait beaucoup de
choses dans ce domaine le plus le plan
d'accélération que le sénat a connu et
voter naturellement il ya contribué
des mesures réglementaires également le
dernière concernait la mise à niveau du
seuil de
du dispositif bouchardeau sur les
enquêtes d'utilité publique mais
beaucoup de mesures de simplification
celles qui ont été par exemple autour de
l'inrap en fallait la liste peut être
fait naturellement sans être exhaustif
mais je crois que nous avons amélioré
les choses sans bien sûr avoir la
prétention d'avoir transformé la france
vous me demandiez dans quelle mesure le
plan a contribué à soutenir l'activité
ben je voulais vous dire que la
consommation la prime à la casse
automobile
j'espère avoir répondu quant aux
collectivités locales
franchement il faut saluer l'effort
qu'elles ont faite le le taux de 54
milliards d'investissements programmés
par elles représentent 54 % de plus que
la moyenne de référence
il suffisait d'un euro de plus pour
avoir le droit au dispositif il ya eu 54
% d'augmentation en plus et je dois dire
que l'ensemble des collectivités locales
ont toutes joué le jeu les quelques
collectivités locales qui n'y ont pas
participé
le ne l'ont pas fait pour des raisons
techniques souvent la hauteur des
investissements et je dois rendre cet
hommage à l'opposition que en aucun cas
dans cette affaire elle n'a adopté à un
quelconque moment une attitude
politicienne elle s'est engagée très
largement très fortement chaque fois
qu'elle l'a pu et à mon avis dans les
communes qui n'ont pas conventionné au
titre du remboursement par les
collectivités qui n'ont pas conventionné
au tout au titre du remboursement du
fctva
il y en a autant dans la majorité que de
l'opposition parce que c'est pour des
raisons techniques et rien d'autre merci
monsieur le ministre pour ce premier
contrat vue
le de mission jean à une toute petite
question à vous poser
vous avez évoqué le fsi le le médiateur
du crédit ayant examiné les 10 mille
dossiers appel constat que pour
certaines pme
il faudra procéder à une
recapitalisation
il est clair que les mois qui viennent
vont être des mois difficiles pour
nombre de pme et il peut se faire que
certaines parmi elles aient du mal à
survivre
et si les fonds propres ne sont pas
conforter et il avait été prévu que le
fsi participent à la constitution d'un
fonds dédié de 200 à 300 millions
précisément pour répondre à cette
nécessité l échéance avait été fixée
initialement au début du mois de juillet
semble que les opérations et du mal à
aboutir et qu' il faudra attendre sans
doute le mois de septembre
avez-vous des précisions à ce sujet
alors d'abord se saisissant du médiateur
du guide du crédit
je rappelle que les deux tiers de ces
interventions ont été salutaires
dix mille entreprises qui sont arrivés
chez le médiateur et les deux tiers ont
trouvé une solution grâce en grande
partie grâce à deux de choses
en réalité le comité financier autour du
préfet qui souvent a pu prendre des
mesures de trésorerie quand c'était
suffisant avec le trésorier payeur
général le directeur départemental de la
banque de france
et puis oseo oseo que le plan de relance
a en permanence soutenue et abondé et
qui a pu prendre jusqu'à 90% de
garanties sur des prêts et donc il ya
très très largement conforté le fsi sa
vocation c'est le fonds stratégique
d'investissement donc sa vocation n'est
pas de voler au secours de toutes les
entreprises en difficulté naturellement
et ses capitaux ni subviendra ne subit
ni serait pas suffisant n'y suffirait
pas mais de choisir
malgré tout quand il ya une entreprise
en difficulté si il ya aussi une volonté
synthétique et je crois par exemple qu'à
un exemple 8 intervenus à neuf reprises
je disais tout à l'heure il ya un
exemple c'est heuliez par exemple
le fsi a
doit investir prévu d'investir 10
millions d'euros
e
avec un tour de table plus large edoc
avec la recherche d'un effet
multiplicateur
mais en même temps ceci doit être
assortie d'une d'une volonté innovantes
sur le concept d'une voiture automobile
qui ne soit pas un traditionnel et où
véhicules non carbonées un véhicule
électrique aurait évidemment de l'avenir
donc est-ce qu'il faudra plus largement
intervenir ultérieurement jusqu'à ce
jour en tous les cas le dispositif a
fonctionné normalement
ce fonds dédié sa vraisemblable création
a été confirmé il ya deux semaines lors
de l'audition de monsieur le directeur
général de la caisse des dépôts et
consignations et la caisse va y mène est
alors oui mais comme elle est partie
prenante dans les faits si bien sur
l'a51 comment non non non non mais il
semblait que via un conseil
d'administration semblait que dans ses
bonnes relations entre la caisse et le
fsi et il était prévu que ce fonds soit
constitué je permets de vous y rendre
attentif parce que je crois pouvoir dire
que le sort leur nombre de pme colle au
médiateur du crédit a considéré comme
viable à condition de le rapporter ce
soutien que semble-t-il certaines
banques résistent à alors qu'on consent
médias mais c'est pas encore calé à mon
avis mais c'est une niche très bien que
ce que ça le soir ça le sou en tous les
cas pour le moment le dispositif a
pleinement joué son rôle sur le
rapporteur général
l'archéologie préventive
nous nous étions efforcé dans le projet
de loi et l accompagnement du du plan de
relance et de trouver un dispositif dans
ce qui n'avait pas été si simple
d'ailleurs pour tâcher d'assouplir un
peu les choses de permettre
l'accélération des chantiers et est ce
que le ministre à des remontées sur la
mise en oeuvre de ce que nous avons voté
deuxième aspect et l'ag et bien
constater le grand succès des mesures
relatives à l'anticipation du versement
du fctva et on pouvait s'y attendre mais
on en a maintenant confirmation mesure
simple approche contractuelle claire et
le dispositif c'est donc très largement
diffusé et son coût budgétaire mais je
dirais que pour une fois c'est une bonne
chose est sensiblement plus élevée que
les 2,6 milliards qui était envisagé
toutefois il y a
je me permets de le répéter une
catégorie de collectivités dont les
investissements n'ont pas pu être
accélérée par le plan de relance ce sont
les intercommunalités nommé dans le
souci de l'efficacité le sénat
n'abandonne jamais mais monsieur le
ministre bien entendu nous n'avons que
ça à faire nous n'avons que ça à faire
répéter répéter pour tâcher de
convaincre et parfois il nous arrive d'y
parvenir savez ce que disait léon blum
sur l'important général les hommes
politiques sont condamnés à se répéter
ou est-ce contredire voilà alors
effectivement ceux qui sont imaginatives
se contredisent et les autres se répète
bon mais et donc les intercommunalités
d'autant que si je ne m'abuse le projet
de texte sur l'organisation territoriale
pourrait mettre l'accent sur les
responsabilités et les compétences des
intercommunalités
donc monsieur le ministre je voulais
vous questionner un peu sur eux sur
l'avenir
et sur ce qu'il conviendrait de faire
pour soutenir l'effort et j'en viens à
un point qui est peut-être plus
important et il convient de raisonner en
se référant à un effet d'impulsion
budgétaire et en 2009
cette impulsion se mettent en oeuvre
notamment grâce au plan de relance mais
et tout dépendra ensuite du point de
savoir quand la reprise pourra
intervenir si elles tardent un peu la
fin de l'exécution du plan de relance
pourrait être à l'origine non pas d'une
impulsion mais au contraire d'un un
effet dépressif dans la seule mesure où
il ne serait pas renouvelé alors faut-il
croire que la recherche de dépenses
d'avenir
parmi lesquels sans doute figurent des
investissements physiques ainsi qu'un
certain nombre de choses qui pour moi
demeure un peu flou au jour
d'aujourd'hui
faut-il croire que ceux-ci soient
l'anticipation et d'une deuxième phase
du plan de relance
et c'est
et la question d'ordre un peu plus
générale que je voulais poser et enfin
pour revenir aux chiffres une toute
dernière chose et en autorisations
d'engagement la dépense budgétaire prévu
au titre du plan de relance
s'établissait à 13,3 milliards d'euros
vous l'avez rappelé et en crédits de
paiement 12,6 milliards d'euros par la
dépense budgétaire stricto sensu
en lisant le rapport que notre excellent
gouvernement vient de remettre pour le
débat d'orientation budgétaire qui se
tient la semaine prochaine et que nous
avons en 2000 commission des finances en
lisant ce rapport je lis que 2,6
milliards d'euros de crédits budgétaires
ont été payés par l'état donc 20% du
montant total des crédits de paiement et
alors
et quelle est la prévision est pour la
fin de l'année 2009 je vous ai bien
entendu tout à l'heure vous avez dit
trois quarts des paiements 75% oui donc
ça veut dire et je souhaiterais que vous
nous confirmez et cette estimation est
que entre le 30 juin et le 31 décembre
et 55 % du montant total des crédits de
paiement devrait pouvoir être versée
donc monsieur le ministre nous ne devons
firme et vous cette évaluation
sur ce point on est déjà à 3 2 donc je
vous le confirme qu'on a dépassé les 2,6
sur ce dernier point monsieur rapporteur
général
on s'en fiche oui vous êtes accablé près
de parme en précisant je comprends donc
je voulais vous dire sur ce point oui la
réponse est oui sur ce dernier point et
nous avons dépassé dessus dessous nous
sommes à 3 2 alors vous m'avez posé la
question sur l'inrap sur l'inrap nous
avons nous avons doté de 20 millions
d'euros
nous avons institué une réduction des
délais et actuellement un décret est en
train de préparer un projet de contrat
de mission pour bien clarifier les
choses et donc la question de savoir si
le dispositif donnait satisfaction
progressivement je crois qu'il améliore
les choses j'ai pour dire les la vérité
j'ai eu quelques remontées encore
naturellement mais j'ai eu le sentiment
que nous étions sur la voie d'une
solution par rapport aux tensions que
nous avons connue avec les fouilles
préventives
vous m'avez posé le la question du
remboursement membres de la fin du
dispositif sur la tva par rapport aux
interco débat je voudrais dire une chose
c'est par rapport à aux projets caressés
par le sénat c'est que l'année à la fin
de l'année pour l'année 2010 nous aurons
des dispositions probablement à prendre
parce que
c'est une profonde révolution que nous
avons déjà institué là c'est à dire que
comment oui donc non mais je veux dire
que d'un remboursement à deux ans nous
sommes passés pour une grande part des
collectivités à remboursement à un an
encore faut-il la soir de manière
pérenne
or je rappelle quand même que i les
engagements doivent aussi être
respectées dans le délai imparti à la
loi prévoit que les engagements doivent
être respectés dans le délai imparti
je ne suis pas absolument certain que
tout le monde arrive à le faire
réellement et même de bonne foi pour la
fin de l'année et donc ils nous auront
sans doute une queue de comète à gérer à
ce moment là et donc l'idée de passer à
une phase ultérieure dans un autre
extension de cette mesure des chères au
sénat dès que je peux comprendre
naturellement elle vient après avoir
consolidé 7,7 cette réforme importante
qu'il faudra faire me semble-t-il est ce
que de deuxième question vous m'avez
demandé si le le deuxième plan de
relance va avec et est envisageable et
que s'il y avait une connexion avec le
grand emprunt il y a évidemment donc il
ya une responsabilité qui a été confiée
à michel rocard et alain juppé à une
procéder à des auditions et c'est après
cela que le gouvernement devra opérer un
choix présent de la république l'annoncé
pour choisir les investissements
d'avenir
simplement pour répondre
plus précisément à votre question ça
c'est la règle générale pour répondre
plus précisément à votre question
moi je crois que dans le plan de relance
tel qu'il a été engagé conduit il y à
des mesures qui sont déjà dans l'esprit
du grand emprunt
il y a une différence importante entre
le plan de relance et le grand emprunt
de dents dans l'essence même c'est
l'immédiateté
le plan de relance se veut immédiat le
grand le grand emprunt ce sont des
actions qui vont être engagées à partir
de 2010 avec donc une procédure plus
plus longue à à plus long terme ça se
situe à des moments différents de la
crise le plan de relance se situe au
coeur de la crise au moment le plus
grave donc avec ce besoin de réactivité
le grand emprunt se veut une mesure
d'accompagnement de sortie de crise et
donc de préparation du pays à une
meilleure compétitivité qui est comme
l'a dit le premier ministre avec un
choix d'investissement à haut rendement
nul dans le plan de relance ya un côté
amortisseur de crise dans le grand
emprunt il doit y avoir une au contraire
une direction pare au comptant mais de
manière complémentaire en tous les cas
est différente
une direction de de compétitivité même
sur la durée et donc ce n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose mais il ya quand même
de mon point de vue est
le travail sera accomplir des mesures
qui seront qu'ils doivent être communes
qui ont été engagés par le plan de
relance poursuivie même par le plan de
relance et qui à mon avis doivent être
de mon point de vue continuer par le
plan de relance
je donne un exemple de ça qui me paraît
caractérisé le président de la
république a fixé comme objectif la la
réalisation de quatre grandes lignes de
tgv
bon bien sûr nous avons commencé et je
prends par exemple un exemple dans le
plan de relance tous ceux que nous avons
encore engagé sur le fameux bouchon de
bordeaux la gare saint jean à bordeaux
il faut naturellement content si on fait
une ligne de tgv que la gare qui passent
là que la gamme la gare de bordeaux soit
en mesure d'accueillir ses tgv
la gare saint-jean il faut qu'elle soit
et donc nous avons déjà dans le cadre du
plan de relance procéder à la réduction
de ce qu'on appelle le bouchon de
bordeaux il ya deux mesures du plan de
relance successives propre à augmenter
la capacité d'accueil des trains c'est
une mesure lourde donc généreux ensuite
il faudra se situer dans la continuité
c'est à mon avis je le crois ça restera
à déterminer mais ça m'étonnerait qu'un
alain juppé soit hostile à cette idée
et donc je pense qui a une et ses
serments à la fois une continuité est
aussi dû aux d'autres mesures monsieur
le président de la commission de
l'économie
oui merci monsieur le président chers
collègues et monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues comme ce qui concerne la
commission de l'économie jouets g
prendre deux secteurs on sent bien que
prendre le plan de relance un temps
d'inertie malgré tout même si vous
l'avez voulu le bien sûr aussi via le
sens de la mise en eux et quand on
regarde les chiffres qui vont dire est
ce qu en direction des infrastructures
du logement qui serait peut être
intéressant de voir même s'il ya une
accélération sur les infrastructures
dans le cadre des contrats de plan état
région
pdmi devoir comme dans certains secteurs
les études ne sont pas assez avancée et
si d'autres secteurs pouvaient avoir des
projets qui n'ont pas été retenus dans
un premier temps alors c'est l'idée d'un
deuxième plan je pense car une analyse
assez fine à faire sur les projets parce
qu'ils ont été listés vous avez évoqué
la volonté du président de la république
de réaliser des lignes tgv
bien sûr mais ça on va déplacer dans le
temps et c'est peut-être le grand
emprunt qu'il pourra le permettre mais
dans un premier temps et très bon ton de
pouvoir apprécier l'impact sur certaines
infrastructures parce que quand on voit
la mobilisation de les autorisations
d'engagement et les consommations
effectifs de comprendre dans un premier
temps c'est quand même insuffisant
il faudrait pouvoir un moment donné voir
l'impact du plan de relance sur des
secteurs qui sont plus difficiles à
m'étendre sur le logement par exemple
j'évoquerai ces deux points sur le
logement on voit que la mise en oeuvre
est difficile malgré tout non mais
peut-être difficile on pourrait avoir
d'autres objectifs
il serait bon de pouvoir analyser
l'engagement bien sûr des offices mais
également l'engagement des collectivités
locales qui ont souvent des difficultés
à boucler ses projets en direction du
logement social
voilà ces deux points si on peut voir
des analyses plus précises dans quelques
mois de façon à pouvoir se positionner
aussi sur le nouvel emprunt et peut-être
trouver des formules adaptées sur le
logement su président le programme
c'était 100 mille logements
nous en sommes à 70 milles engagé donc
me semble pas avoir perdu temple mais
sur par exemple les pl us
nous en sommes à 8800 c'est à dire que
cela allait trois fois plus vite que ce
qui était prévu donc
j'ai le sentiment que ça marche ça
marche comme il faut pour prendre le le
cadre du logement
je corrige un petit peu en disant que je
me dis je vais y aller dans dans l'est
dans les dom n'est pas certain que nous
ayons eu toute la réactivité souhaité
mais j'y vais je pars avec le premier
ministre à la réunion demain pour ça et
j'irai ensuite aux antilles juin faut
que focaliser sur la question du
logement dans le logement
nous posons une question de régulation
budgétaire est ce que il ya des mises en
réserve de 6% c'est la règle qui a été
adoptée pour la loi de finances 2009
mais sur le logement précisément les
mises en réserves sont de 12 % donc y
at-il pas une contradiction entre cette
volonté de consommation des crédits pour
simuler la relancer l'activité et de
l'autre en matière de logement des mises
en réserve qui n'a pas sur le plan de
relance n'a aucune réserve sur le plan
de relance oui mais il ya le plan de
relance d'un côté et puis elle budget
2002 l'autre n'est pas la responsabilité
de conduire la gestion d'image in paris
du logement ce que ce que je veux dire
c'est que devrait quand même qu'il y ait
cohérence entre ce qui se développe dans
le plan de relance il faut qu'un accord
relance qui accélère et l'exécution
budgétaire qui freine les 100000 du plan
de relance il n'y a aucun os aucun
freinage mais vous non oui
du développement et amélioration de
l'offre de logement la mise en réserve
que la mise en réserve générale des
crédits telle 6% elle a été porté à 12 %
donc si c'est pas un coup de frein salir
sans louis non mais je veux dire oui si
hors plan de relance
non je jouerai mon joker vous proposons
de vous adresser au ministre du logement
entre l'exécution budgétaire et le plan
de relance
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant à elisabeth lamure merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre dans la loi l'accélération des
programmes de construction il était
prévu la mise en place d'un régime
d'autorisation simplifiée pour les icpe
c'est à dire un système intermédiaire
entre déclarations et autorisation or
sauf erreur je crois que ce dispositif
n'est pas encore en place que un certain
nombre d'entreprises ont des projets
d'agrandissement de leur établissement
et attendent de pouvoir bénéficier de
cette de ce régime d'autorisation
simplifiée
est ce que vous auriez des nouvelles ou
des éléments et si possible un
calendrier oui oui et elle elle est en
elle et en en cours
elle est sortie du concept nommé je
comprends bien elle est dans les tuyaux
comme on dit elle est sortie du conseil
d'état et je pense qu'elle est en
instance
deux publications elle est rédigée
rédigé comment oui elle est rédigée et
passer au conseil d'état vous savez pas
son aboutissement c'est à dire à quel
moment les entreprises candidates
pourront en bénéficier parce que ce
serait dommage qu'on arrive à la fin
d'année 2009 avec d'étudier de pense que
façon avant la fin de l'année non je
pense que ces quelques celle affaire de
quelques semaines je vous remercie
je pense qu'ils espèrent merci madame le
mur avant fin juillet à quoi j'espère
succès c'est tout à fait possible
oui c'est tout à fait possible christian
gaudin a souhaité vous interrogez oui
monsieur ministre et furets revenir sur
l'homme
le fsi le fle le fonds stratégique
d'investissement qui vous l'avez rappelé
seul objet est donc de soutenir le
développement des entreprises et
notamment des pme les pme prometteuses
ainsi le terme qui figure dans votre
rapport
et je partage jean je conduis un rapport
de contrôle budgétaire sur le crédit
impôt recherche
et on le voit bien dans les grands
groupes
c'est tout à fait naturel de notre
culture mais dans les pme et notamment
les pme prometteuses
c'est pas immédiat l'investissement
recherche développement et pourtant
serait pourtant salutaire me n'est pas
immédiat est la question que je me pose
c'est est-ce qu'il n'y a pas intérêt à
rechercher des couplages stratégique
entre la l'intervention que l'on peut
faire ça pour stabiliser un capital dans
une entreprise au travers du fsi est
quelque part est bien engagée le crédit
impôt recherche vous voyez ce que je
veux dire
parce que dans l'entreprise notamment
d'entreprises prometteuses
on voit bien que son évolution passera
aussi par son engagement recherche
développement
oui et quelque part je trouve qu'il y
aura intérêt à réfléchir au
rapprochement des deux en termes
d'efficience mais je vous comprend quel
est votre sentiment sur le
je jouais pas je partage votre point de
vue mais je pense sont sans l'avoir
vérifié d'ailleurs donc ce que vous me
dites pas me conduire à le faire je
pense que dès lors que le fsi intervient
au capital et prend une part du capital
il s'intéresse à la gestion et il suit
la gestion et donc ils recherchent
évidemment l'efficacité mais vous avez
raison il faut que les deux soient liés
je suis d'accord il faut s'en assurer il
faut s'en assurer oui je suis d'accord
je dire je ne compose bien compris la
question de l'homme madame lamure parce
que comme elle était rapporteur du texte
on a toujours envie de savoir ce que
devient qu'on a engagé et homme
d'engagement dans l'hémicycle et puis
après on dit mme allard et qu'est-ce que
ça devient le bébé n'est pas perdu de
vue
je me tourne vers nos collègues je crois
que plus personne ne demande la parole
sauf donc arrivés au terme de cette
audition merci monsieur le ministre des
tno merci rendre compte et je reviendrai
de l'accomplissement de votre mission et
nous vous inviterons dans trois mois
pour ce compte-rendu trimestriels merci
en espérant que cette relance porte tous
ses fruits et que au mois d'octobre on
voit encore plus clairement à quoi
ressemble la sortie de crise
merci
c'est la fin de l'audition de patrick
devedjian par la commission des finances
du sénat pour revoir cette audition
notre site internet publicsenat.fr
je vous donne rendez vous cet après midi
à 16h30 pour l'examen du projet de loi
hadopi 2 merci de votre fidélité à très
bientôt sur notre antenne